[Music]
are you ready to talk to us oh yeah
you're even more busier today so you're
not packing at the moment but now you're
obviously a huge defender of the Second
Amendment so what was the gun piece of
your political evolution with that how
much was that the whole thing that you
realized that you needed to be able to
defend yourself and you want to do
community to be able to do that and all
that it was a big part but definitely
still the fiscal side was was the
transition part and that's why I went to
Rand at first but no the guns became an
issue for me particularly because it was
so personal for me being on a college
campus you know the graduates graduate
student in 2015 and the campus carry
issue came about again it was I was you
know flabbergasted that it was going for
a third time in Texas of all states and
it was looking at it might not pass
again and I was a graduate here the
scary yeah so campus carry is concealed
carry on college campuses so basically
for example Texas you're allowed to
concealed carry if you're over the age
of 21 if you pass a mental health and a
criminal background check if you go
through all the processes you're
supposed to do then you're able to have
a gun on your person out of your house
so that campus carry is ringing that
that right only bringing in that permit
holder and a will enabling them to be
able to use that same thing in a college
campus on a college campus and so maybe
that's what it does each college have
their own policy on that so it is that
what the fight is so the fly is state by
state that's how it's you know with
campus carry
so in Texas how what they pass the bill
was that every public university and now
Community College and starting August
1st of this year has to have some type
of of concealed carry on campus
legislation the difference they did on
that one last minute though was that
they added amendment saying that every
college gets to put a policies of where
gun freeze
owns within that college would be and so
a lot of my work when I joined soon for
concealed carry when I was with them was
basically looking at every college that
was trying to because they're obviously
anti campus carry and trying to null and
void the whole bill in general and
making sure that they weren't putting up
these outrageous policies where someone
like me wouldn't be able or wouldn't
even want to carry on campus it would be
so hard to right so now they gave them
the loss was written in a way they gave
them so much leeway that they could
create every gun-free zone every faint
yeah and you'd have to walk like you
were doing amazing exact exactly and
that was the intention and we fought
against that and so right now how it is
right now a lot of people are able to
carry on campus in Texas and Georgia
just got the same thing just a couple
weeks ago the concept of gun-free zones
I find really interesting because I see
people on the left constantly screaming
we need more gun-free zone at gun free
zones I the idea of that sounds fine on
the service level but only the bad guys
are going to break the law to bring the
gun there and then you might need a gun
take them out I mean did I just blow
your mind with that right that was
pretty well oh yeah I know I know then
come on those criminals they have hearts
too okay they could change their mind
which is not really good 9 can we change
yeah we're gonna look at you ago like we
can I do it
no no no gun-free zone sorry can't do it
over there really well yeah I think it
sounds so idiotic well I said what you
feel about guns in general just that
weather where you want legalization or
states rights or any of that but the
very concept of this sounds just not
well I'm but but again the messaging is
that there are still people who believe
it and the thing about campus carry too
is what I learned with concealed carry
on campus is that it wasn't just the
left either the ones who are just
waiting Lee I'm anti-gun I don't want
guns anywhere I say that I don't like
Australian gun ban but I really kind of
do type people it's really the people
that I had to convince the most for the
people on the fence or what we had to
convince them else with students can
still carry with them is that those
Republicans right even and not just the
Republican students or the constituents
but even the Republican Congressmen
women who would say that yeah I'm Pro
Second Amendment and gun should be for
all people but on college campuses I
don't know I don't some students is
something about students on campus that
it would for some reason it was okay to
have gun-free zones because maybe
because it's an extension of what we
think about students right now we're
seeing UC Berkeley students and they're
like is that the type of people we want
with guns no I don't yeah exactly but so
we had to convince those type of people
the most particularly women and so
that's where I came in when I was able
to talk to those women and say hey you
know what the reason why I started
fighting for campus carry is because I
want the choice to be able to protect
myself from someone who wants to harm me
look I understand there are physical
differences in regards to their physical
differences or not that person has a gun
I don't who's winning
and so talking to women what I wanted
about that that's when you really that's
when I wasn't really able to get people
to start understanding and getting it
because a lot more people understand the
self-defense aspect of it versus oh the
Second Amendment guarantee guarantees
you that right type of argument yeah is
this an area where you're able to use a
little of their messaging against them
because you can listen to a lot of the
messaging that's going on on college
campuses there's rape culture there's it
comes the rape yesterday and all these
guys are just especially the white guys
they're the frat guys are coming to rape
all the women which we know there's no
rape culture you're really other real
rape culture of course your memory
happens of course every why but are you
able to use that messaging against them
and go ladies if you believe that then
what I'm telling you actually make some
sense absolutely and that's why I
started my organization empowered
because no one was really talking about
that on our side I know granted Kenneth
carries a fairly new concept in the last
10-15 years but to go a step further of
those women who I don't have to try and
you know convince the most and saying
you know what and then to when I talk to
men and they would be at me and say how
dare you try to bring guns on campus
you know women blow a lot and then I
would say well don't you actually want
that woman to be able to protect
themselves
from that and then I think several times
yes several times and maybe cuz I'm a
woman I'm telling them about it and also
a black woman because we use a race card
on that one as well to say actually as a
black person I want to protect myself
from that bigoted that in that scenario
you're talking about if you keep me
defenseless I can't protect myself in
that scenario also as a woman I want
that option to protect myself because
you're also keeping me defenseless in
that scenario so talking to these girls
on campus
sorry women on campus and telling them
that if you so choose to have this as
your tool for self-defense you should
have that right to it
they get it then regardless of what
ideology politics are who they voted for
before that liberal women you know
libertarian classical liberal whatever
Trump people
Bernie people I've seen every single
type of girl or person change their
minds about guns because they see it as
a self-defense issue and people need to
bring the messaging around that versus
what they've been doing before yeah do
you fear any kind of slippery slope with
all this so that you do a campus carry
and let's say in Texas Texas you have
totally concealed carry right now okay I
can still carry out yes and open carry
they have that now but in the terms of
campus carry is concealed right so the
open carry is like when we see these
pictures of like four guys yeah she
appear to be rifles I got Chipotle and
it looks nice it look it looks kind of
scary that just seems kind of scary to
me may not really no no it's definitely
scary well then what then how do we have
that conversation and like the slippery
slope part is where it's like all right
well if everyone can have open carry you
can wander in it to a Chipotle with a
gun on your back and you can have guns
everywhere that that the flip Reese or
book we're going to end up being just
the Wild West like we're going to go to
a place where people are going to start
getting into arguments all the time and
solving it that way you just see that as
a nonsensical starting point I am you're
looking at the gun I'm like man the
points I'm going to make right now
point one and the first of all the vile
less thing I will talk about because
it's going to always hear that
especially on the left and like okay why
you actually read your history because
the Wild West was actually even more gun
control friendly because they made
everybody check their guns with the
sheriff so does some knowledge yeah when
you go to a town you'd have to give your
gun to the sheriff and he would make a
decision for you if you have your gun or
not so it's not the ball s is the
opposite another thing is that yeah
obviously I can't make I can't lie and
say that those people aren't doing that
I definitely don't think that's the
proper way to to get people on our side
but put a majority of the time it's
people that they're open carrying if
they are I still have yet to seem very
many people do it since we've had in
Texas then they're responsible people
they're people that they don't look like
they're threatening or they're going to
harm someone do I still believe and and
know that there are people who are
fearful and they see stuff like that
absolutely me not too long ago I was the
same person and I think you have that
honest conversation is like look I was a
gun rights activist before I even
purchased a handgun because for a long
time I thought maybe the gun will does
go off you know I didn't know the
mechanics of a gun people had they're
not going to learn it just naturally
they have to know it by people educating
them and you have to be patient and stop
yelling at them and their faith and
bringing ar-fifteens in their face
saying you must I demand that you accept
my my side of thinking and talk to them
and have a conversation let them know
that you're a good human being first and
the people behind those guns are good
law-abiding citizens and then you'll
start to change people's minds on the
guns because it's not really about the
gun it's about the person so so I like
that last sentence particularly because
I know that if I had a gun right now any
kind of caliber yeah I would not walk
into a school and start shooting people
I wouldn't walk into a mosque or a
temple or anywhere I wouldn't I simply
wouldn't do that because of my own
mental capacity and I don't not
following an ideology that would want me
to do that or anything of that nature
you see any of this as when we have
these shootings do you see any of it on
the fault of the guns or do you always
believe it's ideology and mental health
and whatever else
I'll bring I never see it as the gun I
see it before even a Wayne LaPierre made
it a popular you know a good guy with a
gun type saying I've never seen it as
I've seen as the people behind it I mean
you can use any tool to harm someone
ut-austin just a couple weeks ago how
the stabbing which is funny because they
turned around and said well campus carry
didn't help us in that situation well
it's not about that it was about the
fact that I'm sorry to talk about the
stabbing of a student with mental health
issues stabbed several people killing
one freshman yeah and a lot of
organizations all of news outlets said
well campus carry didn't help us in that
situation well you know that's part of
it too is that welcoming doesn't because
because it doesn't mean that everyone's
going to have a gun their automatic and
so absolutely wanted to go absolutely
but people don't see that they see
someone was killed and they see that
their guns on campus and guns are
supposed to be enemy there but it's
really it's about the person it's you
know we have to make sure that we are
keeping these people healthy that's
about mental health let's just talk
about that more we don't even have to be
a taboo issue
I hope on our side we'll talk more about
that and we won't be the reactionary
side to the people who are bringing it
up what's what's be the forefront and
the advocates for mental health as much
as we are advocate for for guns why not
so what kind of checks do you think are
actually legit like if you were fresh
right of the law right oh man um you
know I've always sucked to the fact of
campus carry I feel like when you bring
other legislation in there and that it
water is found your argument with campus
carry especially I I don't see myself
changing my views on the fact that
concealed carry is a good way to go when
it comes to going on college campus
maybe because we still have a whole lot
of thursdays to convince before that and
it has helped to say look there are
these checks in place if you are afraid
of student
having a gun on campus look the law that
the state says it's okay so I know you
let your big fan of state administrative
office so at least refresh them in our
scenario to its help its help I will say
that so I will say that yeah right now I
mean I'm not open carry when I work at a
gun range I don't carry the gun range am
I totally fine with that yeah definitely
am I afraid of someone else who has one
no but I do know that there's a fear
behind that and so let's just be smart
about it with them let's take it back
about Trey's common sense and bring it
on our side and use common sense with
with something yeah so what about it
just in the more broad sense about
access to guns like are you okay with
that being a state right you know
whatever the background check is and all
that Jeannette I'll be kicked back to
the state should it be the more local
and anything like that you know and I
know that they do things here in
California differently like why order
Johnny yeah some wieners have it all
begun like so yeah so I let's just all
be like Texas Lucy you know I just I see
I think you know as a you know
libertarian leaning person I do believe
going bring it back to the states and
then having that issue that right to
that is important
same thing with campus carriage I think
you should ever become a federal issue
with campus carry I think it's been good
as a state-by-state issue
yes it's harder but man I think right
now having the background checks and
making sure the people behind them are
law-abiding citizens is important but
again it doesn't matter on the gun
control side they'll take those
law-abiding citizens and make them
demons regardless so that's what we're
seeing right now is that these
law-abiding citizens that statistically
have not have hurt less people than the
general public are demonized every time
these mass shootings and these things
happens in gun-free zones right yeah
answer the fine is so are we having the
same problems with the gun discussion
that we're having with terrorism
discussion in that we only talk about it
right after something horrible happened
I'm sorry so that we can never have an
identity
well now is not the time to talk about
it that n people start screaming about
it because they're they're upset about
dead people which is completely legit
exactly but that in the moments between
we're not good at talking about anything
actually that's when people just start
living their lives and doing everything
so we go from crisis to crisis to crisis
which certainly doesn't help you know
calm argument regardless of what side
you're on on this and when we're having
that issue even now in the age of Trump
uses that people mean look at the gun
industry ask anybody right now and see
if gun sales are down and ammunition is
down because first of all people thought
Hillary was going to be President and so
went up and then now it's down because
people think all it's okay jib it's
Trump is he's with NRA everything's
gonna be fine and they become complacent
and so it's actually harder for the
people like me who are advocates to say
no no no this is not going to be forever
and if you are complacent now especially
on the state level which is where all
the stuff is happening I mean you're
seeing it's right now in California
where the states are really making the
decisions decisions and then say we get
someone who's completely on the left on
next time it's already eight years
behind so you have to continue that
fight even when it's not sexy when you
think that he on the federal level were
good that's actually the most dangerous
time because people are not looking and
people are able to get in in ways that
no one keeping up accountable so that's
the scary part where do you think Trump
fits into all this because the NRA loved
him he doesn't mean like me as a real
gun person one way or another I mean
he's a New Yorker so I just didn't have
a guy to I mean maybe he had security
I'm sure he has security that walks
around with a gun obviously now he's a
Secret Service but like his whole life
he lived in the liberal bubble of New
York City I don't think you I don't like
it just doesn't strike me as a pet issue
of his but the NRA loved him I think
he's said the right things for that
group do you have a real sense of what
he really believes in it you know I
really think he's legitimate about and
that's why you know I said people get
mad me but it was about pro-life issues
and being able to defend myself and I
felt like on those two key issues for me
that he was going to be strong on them
and so far he's been very
strong on both those issues I don't see
him changing physical issues a budget
and health care now that I'm always open
to debating him about because I don't
think he's ever ever was an advocate for
for limited government in that sense but
those two issues I feel are in many ones
he was much more of a Democrat
absolutely although he right now he is
chopping a lot of the the federal amount
that we're spending on a lot of programs
yeah I saw that
yeah well see exactly we'll see yeah
well let's talk about the pro-life thing
for a minute
so I'm pro-choice but I view abortion as
a as a horrible choice that I know
several women that have had abortions
nobody takes it lightly you know
unfortunately a lot of the messaging I
think that you get from the far less
known abortion is they fetishized it
into almost being something cool oh well
me and Don says that she wishes she had
an abortion that type of stuff yeah oh
really I mean I'm not making that up and
you see I see a lot of videos on YouTube
that have you know hundreds of thousands
if not millions of views where they're
just talking about it in such a casual
sort of fun way there was that video of
the girl who worked at an abortion
clinic who had an abortion and she like
videotape the whole thing in it there
was a lot of questions as to whether she
purposely got pregnant or just found me
I mean there's all kinds of crazy crazy
stuff I do it as just as a horrific ly
impossible existential question and that
might go to here ironically would be a
little bit like what got Tommy Laird in
some hot water which is that it
shouldn't be the government deciding
what you should do with your body so I
handed you from there an angle yeah well
there's so much on that I just know are
swollen
I know it's all over Jerry that is the
one thing but but you know actually I
can make a really good argument and what
a lot of libertarians have is that if
you're the government's there to protect
the life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness I mean you don't have any of
that without life so that's a big slide
with me is that yeah you need to protect
life and I think that's why people are
getting away from that I'm going to the
argument up when life begins right and
that's why it's shifted that way because
more people are thinking
well you're right I mean you can't have
life without I mean if you're going to
do that so but I mean I've always been
I'm like angry in that space though
because I think that's a healthy
argument AB like we had you to
anniversary scientists but we could sit
here and say you know I think for the
first month that you can have an
abortion and I think it's a hard choice
but acceptable yeah there's at least
some room to if you believe it's
conception then we can't we can't quite
get there on that that's okay but at
least there's some talking point there
right absolutely
well you know there is definitely
talking points and I want to be honest I
I'm still trying to figure out what I
believe I will say probably right now I
still believe that it comes to you know
conception that life starts there but
you know I'm still evolving is we going
to see the last eight years that might
be have changed and I'm and that's the
thing I'm open to many things but I will
say well that's refreshing motional
Garibaldi worth yeah but we there yeah
it would be a lie for me to say
otherwise but I will say it is primarily
emotional for me I not that you know
I've had to deal with that personally
but life is says something so important
to me I mean women and children are
something so important to me and I just
believe that if we're not protecting
them because they are you know
vulnerable they don't have a voice then
what are we really doing is we can't
protect those who don't have a voice
without know that students or that
that's those who are on born so I will
say in that regards I believe that the
government should protect that that
right the right life so yes we do
hypothetical yeah if you know scientists
could you know come down with the study
that says well we know actually that
it's not consumption but it's six weeks
in something magical happens and that's
when life begins you think you could
possibly I'm really not trying you yeah
I'm just trying to because you're saying
it's about feeling you're you're feeling
right now so if they came charming a lot
like I'm a very large all the feelings
and emotions
but if they could lay down something
that said you know this is what we've
been able to prove do you think that
could be enough to shift you you know I
don't know it would have to be when it
gets to there because it would be a lot
of stuff you know I'm I'm a born-again
Christian and that was seven years ago
and so that's very important to me and I
just know that that's something that you
should not be advocating for now do I
really think it's really that question I
think we'll have other if even that
happens that there's so many people who
are going to say well no okay we'll
start six weeks but anything after that
and then people want the right to
continue on I think that argument is not
going to end but yeah I really can't I
can't say whether or not it's the
science is there if it's going to in
start at six weeks if I change my mind
because of that how about we'll do this
again that's a good money or ten months
and we'll see okay there you go okay
well that sounds like I just [ __ ] my
mind my decisions in Miami about
yesterday okay we'll continue with more
than Tony and her political spectrum
today yeah there's a movie there is okay
yes so as a small L libertarian does the
pro licen then put you in a different
tough spot because you don't want the
government to then have to pay for a
child but if a woman that is you know
poverty-stricken or whatever can't
afford to have this child then the
government says we'll abortion is
illegal so you're going to have to have
this child does the state then have any
responsibility to help them
you can't like that idea as a
libertarian right well I don't even get
bad like someone who advocates for any
personal responsibility to say that
there's only two choices there is that
oh that the government says you can't
have an abortion so therefore it has to
also take care of your children
we don't do husband where anybody else
no I mean that's not I mean if there's
instance after instance where you're not
doing that so just to say that if that
scenario happened that we suddenly have
to also at that time take care of that
child
of course I think there should be some
type of safety net and you're most
libertarians believe that this is how
long it is to the point where it keeps
someone from having that responsibility
for their own life and the life that
they choose to or the life that they
have and they take care of no I mean I
think that's where the community should
come in where you know the places of
faith or what other state that you have
the people around you should be helping
with that and I think that's what we
advocate for as libertarians is that no
one said that the government is supposed
to be taken care of of us in that in
that way even when it comes to abortion
yeah so you basically see this is a
false choice and regulation yeah to say
that has the two scenarios and that's it
you choose one and if you're not you're
not malleable cheering I don't believe
that yeah all right well this hour is
clues I wrap this thing in a nice bow
for all the people out there that are
having their own political evolution and
I think you've been very frank and
honest here and all that about your own
continuing evolution which is a
beautiful thing and that's what I try to
bring to this every week what would you
say is the most important thing for
someone that wants to get in the fight
even if they disagree with you
politically you would think that and
watch this for an hour and go man she's
bonkers for my hair yeah but what would
you say to them about just like having
that moment and being able to you know
talk about things that your parents may
not like or that your family may be
inside with or any of that I would say I
mean fight on I mean that sounds so like
like I swear I'm 27 guys like that
sounds so like I'm in my 80s or
something but no seriously it's going to
be hard I mean if you really want to
make a difference having the
conversations that are needed most
people are not going to do that keep
keep at it I mean because those people
who believe they can make a difference
are going to make a difference we see it
already today so keep on and there other
people doing the same thing you're not
alone but it's important we need that we
need out of the country especially now
so all right well it's absolutely flew
by I didn't look down on one album
impressive are you awesome
very impressive war on Antonia check out
her website it's Antonia okhla for calm
[Music]
you
[Music]